hello everyone Perry back here with
another Collider exclusive interview and
this is a special one because I have
admired this individuals work for way
too long I've always wanted to talk to
you Xavier I'm so I'm just so happy
you're here right now Xavier motet
creatures creature master I really do
look at some of your work and consider
you a genre icon at this point well
thank you thank you thanks I wanted to
introduce our audience to your work in
general but also a little to you and
just like what you're into and I kind of
wanted to start at the very beginning
was there that one film or that one
thing you saw that made you say I gotta
get into the filmmaking industry yeah my
mother told me why not the first time I
was in in a theatre me see in a movie I
stand it up in the in the middle of the
movie and I said I want to do that
I don't know what I mean because I think
I was seeing a Bambi but me so it was a
cartoon nice Disney story but and and I
was all my life drawing but I remember
they were one of the first movies I
really remember by myself I was in the
theater was seeing a return of jadeite
and I remember that it was totally blow
in my mind everything in one point I
think in the in the in the war in the
forest of Endor I I had a moment that I
took my eyes out of the screen and so my
friends my mother and then I went back
to the movie that's the only moment that
I remember out of the this world I was
crazy with with all these a lot of
creative stuffs in
my childhood it brokes my my mind after
that I was all the time drawing and
shaping with clay monsters all the time
monsters creatures
I mean aliens or whatever so I was crazy
with gene Hanson as staffs or the
library the Dark Crystal and all the
George Lucas movies of course and
everything which had something unreal
some creatures some techniques that
makes you feel that something impossible
is happening and then I was all the time
looking for for scene making offs and
learn techniques or things but in my
childhood I had only paper a pencil
Cline and that what I use it I was
drawing drawing shaping and making my
own stories in in paper so that was my
childhood I asked it in my family for a
videocam video camera but was suspensive
and it's not like now everybody can have
a video camera with a with them a while
but in my times I'm very old 42 so so
that was hard I I had to wait till I was
studying the university student arts so
I started started earning a little of
money and I bought my first video cam
and then with the video cam and my
friend David and we started learning by
ourselves shooting editing and doing
everything and then I moved to Madrid
and
before that I lived in little cities so
in Madrid I discovered that there was a
opportunity to to make the dreams of
living in the business of cinema and so
I started meeting meeting people and
doing shorts and doing things and
finally one day I found a paper of a
commercial paper for a workshop of
effects workshop and I joined the
lessons to learn how to do these kind of
things but I was with my personal
intention that was meeting the the
teacher and let him know that I thought
I had a perfect body to make all these
creatures that I thought if these guys
not only a teacher and he's sometimes
working in movies he will appreciate
that so you know I'm so tall so skinny I
thought I'm the perfect structure to
compose over me whatever you think so
yes in the moment he saw me he thought
the same so that was like a first
psyched love so we we've been working in
a lot of movies after that so but the
first time we did something was him in
Brian goodness beneath Stillwater and
then other effects artist so me and they
start asking for me asking for me so I
always said that the effects guys where
my bed my best agents they made my my
career start growing as a snowball are
you constantly getting offers for
opportunities like that now yeah yeah
but the big change was after mama
before that I've been doing monsters and
creatures and in Spain so in Spain there
are a very little business of science
fiction and horror movies so I was
working little by little not much but
after five years working in Spain I was
in Houston in the Fantastic Fest mm-hmm
and I met there a special place yes it's
an amazing night
that was crazy week I've yet to go but
every person that I know that's been
there is always like that was the
craziest week I mean I keep trying to
make it a priority it's so close to TIFF
but I think next year it's it's the real
deal there's no more backing out of it I
enjoyed so much but I I went quit with a
crazy bunch of friends so that made a
bigger my experience
so in in this team led the the director
very crazy a nice guy told me there's
one guy that wants to meet you he his
name is Andy machete machete okay I I
met him for the first time in in Houston
so he was there showing his short mama I
was only a short but he was looking for
the production to make the movie so he
was speaking with me about he thought
that I will be perfect to play the role
so I said okay it's amazing it sometimes
happening in the in the festivals you
know people that want to make his chart
but not many much happen yeah I feel
like Fantastic Fest should use that in
their marketing campaign it's like we
brought these two great genre creators
together yeah okay so sorry
personally I
to say sorry for my Emily's because I
know he's a I grab and try it but you
know making monsters I don't need to
speak very well so but can you repeat
the why use oh I just think that
Fantastic Fest the Film Festival should
actually use your story to draw more
people in it's it's like there's this
big event in Austin and look at these
two great people that you know that we
are together yes a festival in general
is a is the best place to know people in
to to share projects and to make teams
to get stronger so well was it was
amazing one year later he called me and
the here mother'll was going to produce
and then it becomes a reality and not
even the movie was the the cliffhanger
in my career was the video that YouTube
video the movement test I am obsessed
with that but that is one of the most
incredible things I've ever seen that
was the point when I felt a change you
said a lot of people is getting you
offers yes that was after the video cos
after the movie you can see the movie
okay is everything you want but it has a
few parts in digital and the people is
seeing a lot of digital stuffs so when
something is digital you automatically
think that everything is digital the
people doesn't understand my for
proportions so they think ok is a
technique something like that so the
producers here more Barbara they told me
do you mind if we share and Internet the
the movement test because a lot of
people is saying to Guillermo that is
digital so I said ok no no no problem
let's go I think it's better for me and
that was that was it a they shared a
video it becomes very viral mm-hmm and
after this video I start receiving a lot
of affair offers a lot of directors
producers told me always when we start a
project he they they start speaking me
about when they saw the video they start
thinking about I would be perfectly for
the role I remember Alexander Asha acts
I told him me that telling me that and
he told me that a lot of people in the
business so that and they want to work
with you so and yes
this point I think in in the 1913 the
year 1913 I felt after that I felt how I
change it I remember vividly seeing that
video for the first time and that was
the point that I was introduced to your
work and I did not stop talking about it
because it really is something else I
didn't want to get your opinion on how
the industry especially from then to now
is marrying the practical work that you
do with the digital effects do you see
things improving in that sense well I
think when the digital effects started
it was special was something new or
something and that was improving and and
people and industry drive crazy with
that so they started doing too much and
I think in the last years they they
start thinking about maybe they they did
too much and they need to go back and
use the practical effects and then add a
little digital maybe to help
but not doing everything in and digital
cuz we after a long time improving the
digital we still know that it's it's not
the same
we felt we feel when something is real
when in Luke is speaking to the other
and the Muppet okay you know is
something different is but the Luke is
looking at his eyes and you feel he is
speaking with somebody with a Frank of
boys it's it's alive is something real
but when you see they they the other in
the in the Phantom Menace and it's it's
it's other thing if you you feel it's
not alive it's not real I think this
different is it's all is it's all so for
me it's way way way better to work with
all the practical you can and then if
you can help find a little help how have
you not been in a Star Wars movie yet
you sound like you're probably the
biggest star Wars fan yeah it's like the
point to close the circle in my life I
love the Jenner I love all the same
fiction movies and horror movies but the
first and most important and that made
me focus in creatures was the Star Wars
and I said a lot of time a lot of in a
lot of place you know you need to to to
hope and to speak about something to
make the universe make it happen
and I'm sure it will happen but oh I
wouldn't bet on it
I hope and
nine principle movies are doors but
there's mandalorian there we and you
serious project day you know there's a
lot of projects growing I hope one day
make my dream if you could carve out
your dream role in the Star Wars
universe what would it be
maybe just like your character
preference yes I I always say that for
me no matter how little part I only want
to be part it's like checking my
principle dream but if you can choose
you have the power to choose I think I
rather do to work as a Seath I said
something in the dark side okay I think
I will enjoy better I can understand
that or whatever reason I've always been
drawn to not even necessarily the Sith
but just like the Empire and the
organization of the first order
something about that just speaks to me
I'm rooting for you I was actually
wondering what what do you call what you
do do you prefer a creature actor or
what what is the title that you want the
industry to be ended I read it
monster performance I don't know where I
read that I don't know if I read in in a
dog Joan story or and I use that I don't
matter how to call it the reality is I'm
an actor comedy and drama and everything
but the most successful and what the
people knows most of me is the horror
angry and say fiction creatures so yes
I'm sometimes that but all the time I'm
an actor so at this point I am mad
when you're getting into makeup you've
got to be there for a very very long
time getting it done and then once
you're in full makeup there are certain
things you can't do for the extent of
the day so what are some you know cheats
or ways to pass the time that you've
come up with over the years well I like
to try always to open by my team and
speak about everything and and make
jokes and make fun to to make the time
better but you try to be very still
because you know you can move very
comfortable whatever you want but if
something sticks out you need to get
another half an hour fix him so I've
tried to be still to relax to lie down
in a sofa in the free time or in a chair
and then do my job and try to do to
respect the work of the effects guys and
and to do everything as fast and
professional you can do to because it's
not especially fun to work in these
conditions a but after five six hours
sometimes more of a full makeup and feel
uncomfortable because you can handle the
food or whatever you sometimes have
problems to go to the bathroom
so there's a lot of stories with that
when you eat you try to do in a mirror
trying not to get dirty and then makeup
and it's a weird great story but after
all these issues of these problems when
you do something when you finally should
take and you go to the
and see what you're doing with the light
with all the art with all the work
everybody did in your body and you
finally see the frame everything worth
everything worth because I'm an actor
but before that I'm a fun a fan of these
movies and totally I see that is like
beautiful of all of the big franchises
and big filmmakers you've worked with is
there any one set in particular that you
got there and you're like I cannot
believe I'm on the set of Game of
Thrones the set of an alien movie
working with Andre over at all anything
at all well since I started I was
receiving gift from the life all the
time
non-stop and I remember in Spain when I
said I always when they work with Alex
and ecclesia it's a very important
director Spanish director
so I've been working in the three five
five different shows with Alex and I
glacier I remember when I said I wish I
would work with Guillermo del Toro so I
did a four shows producing a directing
or directing with a mother so I
everything is happening I said I wish
work with Tim Burton Tim Burton so I
know it's gonna happen and was very
close to happen one and a half year ago
was very close so one and a half years
ago so that was that for Dumbo
yes that the fact he wanted to meet me
after a cast but finally couldn't happen
because the schedule was so restrictive
in this production and I already had a
deal close a deal with Slenderman
oh yes two years ago 2018 with
Slenderman so I couldn't do all the time
that Disney wants for me so finally it
doesn't happen but eh
now I know Tim Burton knows me now or
show me I hope he remember me for the
next projects we will attack again like
Star Wars it sounds like boring to me I
want it to happen yeah yeah well thank
you what is it like working with some of
these directors doing the type of work
you do because I love hearing about how
someone works as an actor's director so
is there any specific way you like to
get notes from your director I think I
don't understood they the first question
you did when you're when you're on set
with work been working with one of these
directors is there any specific way you
like to get notes from them to change
your performance for certain takes I
know no specific way I think in all the
time we are I'm director I'm a writer I
do my so I did everything by myself in
my first years a lot of short seven so I
can't resist to try to get better
something when I see is something that I
don't like so I was for a long time
learning to shut up and do my work but
the most of the times in my part that is
very specific the most performance the
most of the directors used to to ask me
and to give me a lot of freedom to
propose they they speak with me and show
me the designs
the intention the story I read and
discrete playing before working so
sometimes we make a movement test and we
together find how we want it to work so
I think they know they knows that I am
their their best to know what my body
can do and they usually give me a lot of
a lot of freedom even in a lien for
example another dream another between
yes I mean covenant it was amazing
because they not even hire me to work
moving my body no they contacted me time
before to tell me about the creature a
new creature and some like a
brainstorming they gave me some cues and
they gave me time and a space to find
something and proposed so they wanted me
thinking about the the style the mood
everything so that was not only the gift
of working in alien was a bigger gift
receiving this appreciation of what I do
so I was doing work in my home in Spain
looking for something and speaking with
them and finally they they fly me to
London and we captured the movements and
then they apply in it in the CGA so cool
I also did want to talk specifically
about scary stories which people can own
on dvd/blu-ray digital and I am a big
fan of the movie there are a whole bunch
of creatures that were in that original
book when you first were contacted did
you know exactly who you were going to
play
did you get to pick what you did was two
summers this last summer no the previous
one was crazy was crazy cuz I was in
Pinewood in Toronto in the studio's I
shoot him eat Chapter two and an episode
of Star Trek another dream they were
filming in the same studio as scary
stories to tell in that art so was so
easy when when I received they knew that
they wanted me to play one of the
creatures was so easy I said okay I'm
here when where but so I was speaking
with miles tails is the producer is the
producer of mama of the strain I work it
with him a few times so he showed me the
books I already read it and so in an
Internet some things about these stories
because I I always are researching and
and enjoying cuz when I read something
in in any website or any magazine about
new projects that I think I could be
part of a I pay attention I love
everything but in these moments I said
hey Guillermo it's gonna produce this
movie for sure he's gonna think of me so
what is this is a group of books so I
start searching I saw even shorts that
was already shooted along yeah like Oh
little shorts about the where's my toe
so I'm the other stories so I never met
before but I start researching so when I
was in Pinewood
and they calling me a continent they
told me what story was the one they want
me to play so I already know when Yermo
decided to do the movie and so the
illustrations he decide to make one of
the illustrations on me because of
course he knows me and and they're so
similar in my profile so skinny one of
the you know what I know I'm speaking
about so what's so easy was a I was in
the same studio the role was made for me
it's like a normal company I did that
amazing makeup so light so easy to wear
to to move so when I was in the makeup I
was exactly the same illustration so I
feel I felt like a low it by the
original outdoors to do whatever I want
because this is the truth I mean I am
the monster
I own that monster nobody can say how it
is so but they gave me freedoms so it
was a little part and was so easy was so
so in when you work with you here mo do
you feel that everything knows exactly
what they're doing it's like he do a
very big pre-production he's always
thinking about everything in writing and
drawing and everything everything goes
so clear to the moment they everybody
say action so was so easy
he's one of my favorite people in this
industry I'll never forget going to the
set of crimson peak and seeing the full
house built on the soundstage but also
seeing all the little details he put
into the the make
head so he could plan his shots it's the
attention to detail is incredible
he loves the things that the people do
with his hands the art he loves that so
he he make a crew of amazing artistic
people with a lot of talent so since the
moment they start to draw the first
rouse to the moment everything is
materialize it is physical everything is
done by people so talented so you feel
you feel when you're in the stage it's
it's amazing you know like you said the
house of crimson peak was great sequence
you're in a dream you're insane it
really did feel like that standing there
so we have to wind down but because
today is Halloween when we're recording
this interview I've got to Halloween
questions for you one are you gonna
dress up do you have any plans to
celebrate the holiday I used to avoid to
the makeup and the dress and everything
and when I'm not working because you
know it's too hard too much time too
much well when I have free time my life
I love to see my face and but two years
ago I was in Halloween in LA and I was
dressed by I was dressed as the frozen
princess oh my god you know all the time
scaring people I love to make a white
for the week and blue dress perfect
what's your go-to Halloween movie to
watch
hey I'm not sure I haven't decide is
that the fact I think I saw every movie
a lot of movies so you know I'm from
Spain so in Spain there's no day the
custom the custom that you here have
with Halloween there's no much party you
know people don't think very much about
that so you call it a custom I might
call it an obsession or at least for me
it is for you that intense yeah I love
it I just love that we it gives us an
excuse to have a full month to celebrate
genre yes I did in Spain and a lot of a
how to say custom yeah parties oh yeah
yeah yes we we did a lot but and not for
Halloween only because you want and I
did all my life but after starting
working as a most performance yeah now I
do it for work and when when I have free
time I I like not - you could celebrate
year-round I'm jealous
what about Halloween candy if you had to
pick one piece of Halloween candy what
would it be
it's a cos I never was
[Music]
Galgo golasa how to say in English
somebody that likes so much they destroy
we're having a sweet tooth sweet tooth I
don't really have that ever was salty I
like to eat so bad this kind of the
candies and I don't like very much but
maybe they sceetos okay okay if you
don't have the sweet tooth
I feel like skittles are probably the
right way to go yeah I'm here thank you
so much for coming in today this was
seriously a major treat for me cuz I
really admire your work so thank you so
much thank you it's a pleasure guys
do not miss scary stories to tell in the
dark cereal silly it's a great watch for
Halloween and because I think genre
movies should be celebrated year-round
any time of the year so get it then DVD
blu-ray digital any way you want don't
leave this interview without liking and
sharing it and I'll see you soon with
more of them